yeah i'm not gonna drink a big fat glass
of milk on camera
that's not a good look fiance maya
rudolph made her return to snl
as host over the weekend and her first
impression of the night
was none other than queen b beyonce
knowles carter
it is truly an honor i know
i cannot believe you're on hot ones now
i feel you
i i still can't tell if this is beneath
me
maya did a spot-on parody of the
39-year-old singer
and her look from this year's grammy
awards
thank you so much this sketch had the
songstress joined
sean evans played by mikey day on hot
ones
where beyonce had trouble answering
questions while eating some hot wings
beyonce sorry not good
your girl's throat just closed up for a
second
let's do the next wing okay are you sure
definitely boo definitely okay when b
couldn't handle the heat
she hilariously called her hairstylist
over for some assistance
i need you to take my wig off
put six ice cubes up on my head
then put my quick back home
but b you on camera i don't care
take my wig off host of hot ones
sean evans himself took to instagram to
praise rudolph's performance
saying quote this was so good
it makes me so happy to be here in the
place that i love i can't tell you
of course the snl alums return brought a
ton of great moments
including this sweet shout out during
her monologue
some of you may know me because well i
used to work here
and
and some of you may know me by the name
mommy
because i gave birth to you i have four
incredible kids and they're all here
tonight don't make me cry
saturday night also had maya bringing
back another
iconic impression of hers vice president
kamala harris good evening america
i'm vice president kamala harris in
another sketch
as maya takes a stroll down memory lane
she gets a little help from some
familiar faces
hey there maya yep that's right rudolph
was reunited with former snl cast
members
tina fey kristen wiig and rachel dretch
maya rachel oh my god hi
the water's out in my building so i just
decided to come take a bath in the
studio
while this episode brought the laughs it
also brought a
powerful moment from cast member bowen
yang
during the weekend update portion of the
show yang joined colin jose where he
opened up about the rise in anti-asian
violence
things for asians in this country have
been bleak
for the past two weeks look i'm just a
comedian i don't have the answers but
i'm not just
looking for them online i'm looking
around me
the gofundme for sea agency the
grandmother who fought back against her
attacker raised
900 000 which she immediately
gave back to the community that's where
we are
as asians now come meet us there after
getting emotional
bowen shared a mandarin sentiment that
he hopes will inspire others to take
action
in mandarin there's a cheer that goes
diao which basically means
fuel up i don't know what's helpful to
say to everyone but that's what i say to
myself
fuel up do more it's the year
of the metal ox which basically means a
car
so everyone get in buckle up it's no p
breaks we
write it down grandmas